[Music]
hi everyone i'm marco and i'm tanisha in
the security spotlight we heard about
the importance of a zero trust approach
to security and in our demo today we
will show you how to implement zero
trust access to be more secure and more
productive and a quick shout out to our
audience this is truly live dive into
the chat we want to hear from you tell
us what you do and where you're joining
from we can see you check it out marco
sure enough we can see everybody down
here and we're so excited to interact
and talk to you all today
if you're still hanging out on the next
event website click on the blue button
that says join the interactive
experience to activate these features
okay so let's get into it we're going to
cover three things
one how your entire workforce can
securely access legacy and modern
applications without exposing your
network to attacks and two how you can
get better protection against threats
and data loss right from within your
browser and three
how you can gain visibility into unsafe
activity even if users aren't on a
corporate network or device and we're
going to do all of this with beyondcorp
enterprise beyondcorp enterprise or bce
as we call it is google cloud's zero
trust access solution with bce you can
use chrome to access apps and resources
in the background google's network
protects and proxies traffic enforcing
access policies these policies use
factors such as identity device info
location and third-party signals to
authorize access to apps and data that
you need to do your job
that's awesome marco so let's get to the
good stuff think about it how easy is it
for your developers to work remotely and
securely right now
we know it's a tough task we know that
making life easy for developers while
also protecting your code is critical
that's why our new beyondcorp enterprise
feature client connector is so important
it enables zero chest access to legacy
thick client applications yeah i think a
lot of people run into that today
so let's take a look at how developers
would use it
we set up this laptop for the symbol
group
by the way they're a fictional company
symbol has been around since the 1970s
and they haven't modernized all their
applications sound familiar one of their
main developer applications is still
hosted in a private data center yeah i
see this quite a bit until recently
simple developers didn't have a way to
access this application remotely without
a vpn the security team had constant
concerns that remote users could expose
the network or even worse their source
code to attacks or hackers but now using
beyondcorp enterprise client connector
they can access client server apps
without a vpn
let me show you how simple developers
would connect via ssh to their git
repository and before i show you let me
just say
don't blink or you might miss it it's
that simple
so let's go ahead and swing on over to
our developer machine
from here i can simply open up google
chrome
once google chrome has actually loaded
you can see i've authenticated to my kit
application repository already up in the
right hand corner i simply click on my
endpoint verification extension
and from here i click on start
connection my endpoint is being postured
in the background and a secure
connection is being made to gitlab
from there i can simply then once it's
turned green of course minimize my
browser
and then on the left hand side i'm going
to go ahead
and open up my terminal application this
is my thick client application
i'm going to then go ahead and run a git
clone
and that's actually going to pull down
the code from git to my local machine
and there's my application pulled down
locally onto my endpoint
i know that probably seemed pretty
straightforward
but what you might not have noticed was
first
there were no clients it's all in the
browser you probably already had open
second
in the background continuously
validating the identity and the device
and a bunch of other factors
is our identity where proxy and third
our tcp proxy seamlessly and securely
forwards all the traffic the fact that
developers around the world can do this
remotely
simply and securely
without all the hassle of a vpn is
pretty awesome
and with beyondcorp enterprise workers
are only allowed access to applications
they're permitted to use so we prevent
unwanted lateral movement across the
network
so audience we want to know would you
use this method for remote access in
your organization
awesome
now let's see how your workforce can
securely access modern web applications
even from non-corporate devices
let's look at how symbol does it for
their extended workforce their call
center contractors
meet rhonda she's one of thousands of
remote contractors who help with symbols
24 7 support during the holiday shopping
season so security community can you
share in our chat
in the past year have you onboarded new
temporary workers did you send them a
laptop or make them install software so
they could be more secure
looks like that would be a yes
contractors also tend to be more
vulnerable to attacks last year 44
percent of organizations experienced a
breach and 74 percent of those breaches
were the result of giving too much
privileged access to third parties so
for symbol keeping those users off the
corporate network decreases the risk of
being exposed to attacks like ransomware
and here's where using beyondcorp
enterprise comes through again for
symbol contractors and other employees
are able to byod on board quickly and
use a device that they feel comfortable
with while bce layers of protection keep
them secure
that way rhonda can have secure access
from her own device with clear
separation between work and personal
activity let me show you exactly what
she sees as she begins her day
she first navigates to her google chrome
browser
then she navigates to her symbol call
center application
we'll enter in our credentials
we'll then do two f two factor
authentication with our time security
key
now that we've passed
two factor authentication
we are in our symbol call center
application
you saw rhonda log into chrome with her
symbol credentials this is what we call
a beyond core protected profile it
extends threat and data protection as
soon as she logs in as you can see our
agentless approach means no additional
software she gets right to work on her
own device rather than picking up a
laptop from it and waiting hours while
everything gets configured therefore
saving time and money
awesome demo tanisha and the thing about
zero trust access is that we don't
automatically trust ronda just because
she has login credentials authorization
is continuous
not just when she first logs in beyond
corp enterprise enforces symbols
contractor access policies based on her
identity and contextual information
about her device and location as well as
the fact that she's authenticated with
her titan key
so security community we want to know
what do you all use for multi-factor
authentication
sms codes security keys
maybe an authentication app or maybe
something else completely hopefully it's
not nothing
for me it's my security key every day
especially since i don't always have my
phone on me
yeah same here and they're so easy to
use and they provide the strongest
protection against phishing regardless
of what you use some form of
multi-factor authentication is critical
for basic security hygiene and we highly
recommend it especially for remote
access
so let's take a look
i don't know if anybody has anything
looks like um
most people use let's say security keys
b awesome that's what we love to hear so
let's get back to ronda who just
authenticated to the app and explore how
we can integrate threat and data
protection
right from within our browser
great let's see our get to work and show
a bce protect symbol their customers and
rhonda with ease it's been a really busy
day she doesn't have enough time to
finish processing a batch of customer
refunds before her next call she wants
to save the customer credit card
information to a local file and do the
refunds when things slow down
but saving the sensitive information to
another location is against symbol
security policy let me show you her
experience
let's navigate to our credit card file
and let's download this so ronda can do
the refunds at another time
as you can see she's blocked you can see
a message appear at the bottom that
prevents her from doing so
yeah exactly you can actually see where
the credit card pdf has sensitive or
dangerous content inside of it
and i'll show you a policy that's been
configured for symbol
that will detect risky behaviors just
like these
so let's go ahead and look at our
administrative console here
admin.google.com
over on the left hand side
you can see the security menu
and if you scroll down underneath
security you can actually see data
protection
and we're going to go ahead and
authenticate obviously as administrator
securely so let's go ahead and type in
our password
and once i've authenticated i'll be able
to go ahead and look at my data
protection policies you'll notice here
it says manage rules so we're going to
go ahead and drill into manage rules and
we can actually see now the credit card
detection policy that run is hitting
right here i've also got detectors for
things like social security or even
detecting code that's being copied or
pasted or shared
by the developers so
as the admin you can decide if you want
to automatically block user actions as
symbol is done here
or if you want to trigger warning to the
user instead
and in addition to things like credit
card numbers you can also set specific
dlp policies to detect file type as
source code so that way you can protect
sensitive information and code by
monitoring controlling or even blocking
what people upload or download
exactly we can use very granular
policies for this type of information in
order to protect against exfiltration so
we just showed you some of the types of
data protection policies you can set up
you can also customize access policies
and the changes take effect in real time
this is a really big deal because you
get continuous checking of whether a
user is in or out of policy giving you
up to the second security controls
in fact
let's make an update here in real time
for ronda so okay community we're going
to ask you which policy we should change
is it her location maybe her operating
system policy or whether or not she's on
a corporate owned device
please chime in here we'd really love to
understand and hear what you guys deem
important while we wait for the results
to come in
i will say that i see these kinds of
things all the time with my customers
they want to be able to dynamically
change policies depending on their
circumstances in particular some
customers are really interested in
controlling for location perhaps
limiting access to only certain
countries
additionally if a company is going
through an org change or maybe a merger
being able to change access policies for
select groups of users or departments in
real time is crucial and beyond these
three choices in the poll there are many
other ways to customize your access
policies based on what your organization
needs
so let's go ahead and look back at the
polls
and it looks like corporate on device
so awesome
i love it and thanks for everybody
contributing let's go ahead and do this
right now
so we're going to go ahead and jump on
over into our gcp cloud console and from
here we can see our identity where proxy
you can actually see our symbol git lab
for our developer
application we can also see our call
center application
and again these applications could be
anywhere for this demo they're in gcp
we're going to go ahead and select the
call center application and down at the
bottom we can see
rhonda over on the right hand side in
her application access policy let's go
ahead and edit that and we're going to
go ahead and remove the existing access
policy that's allowing access from
europe and the us
and we're going to go ahead and delete
that one and we're going to add a new
role
we're simply going to go ahead and
select cloud iep iep web app user and
then from there we're going to go ahead
and select the access policy which
everybody chose and that was
required corporate device right
okay just want to make sure i remembered
that correctly let's go ahead and save
that in place
click save
and when we save that policy it's
actually going to be propagated across
the world within a very short period of
time
all the proxies across google's global
network are immediately updated so the
next time any user tries to access a
protected resource they're evaluated
against that new policy set
we mentioned continuous authorization
earlier and this is a key part of that
authorization is not a one-time
occurrence so even if you begin a new
session that doesn't mean you'll have
perpetual access
exactly and for companies like symbol
that employ hourly and temp workers the
ability to dynamically update access
conditions is important for instance
they could set these policies so workers
only access applications and resources
during their shift hours or working days
or only allow access from only allow
access from specific geographies they
also may want to require that devices
have the most up-to-date operating
systems and security patches so this is
an important condition to manage
especially for all the contractors using
their own devices
exactly
so because ronda doesn't meet that
condition which i just updated
she will no longer be able to access the
call center application
now
i think we've all faced this and it's
one of the most frustrating things about
remote access especially when you're
using the vpn you think you should have
access to something but for some reason
it's just not working
it's the worst
so let's see if our real-time change
worked so when rhonda tries to open a
new task in the call center application
let's take a look at what she sees
let's navigate back to her home
and she's denied access as a result of
the change marco just did but once again
bce has rhonda covered she can report
this error using our new feature the
beyondcorp enterprise policy
troubleshooter which informs end users
that they're blocked and tells them how
to get help quickly so as you can see
here she would follow the prompt to
email the admin to get help
let's go ahead and email our admin
our admin is now notified of us being
blocked with beyond corp enterprise
policy troubleshooter admins can quickly
fix issues that are blocking users
keeping them productive
yep you bet let me show you what the
symbol admin would see on the other side
of this request and how they can unblock
users like rhonda
so we're going to go ahead and switch
gears let's go over to gmail
another google application
and it looks like we got a notification
for credit card detection which is good
so
we know if rhonda is taking some
interesting actions within her endpoint
oh and it looks like we just got an
email from rhonda because she's actually
been blocked to an application there's
the link that she sent over so let's go
ahead and click on that and we'll
automatically be logged directly into
the google cloud platform
so from here i can actually see the
different policies and bindings that are
in place so let's go ahead and select
the call center application and over on
the right hand side here we can actually
see
uh the the uh the granted conditions or
the denials themselves so let's go ahead
and look at the binding details so
interestingly here we can see that
rhonda failed to meet any of the listed
access levels and sure enough it's
requiring a corporate device which was
not granted so i normally go back in a
blocker by updating that policy so our
access level is evaluated like any other
contractor but we're going to keep
moving just the interest of time
sounds good that was so easy by the way
yeah super easy now let's look at bc can
give us better visibility into unsafe
user activities whether they're
unsuccessful access attempts like we
just saw
or other anomalous activities across the
apps that bc protects
let me pull up the security dashboards
in chrome and give you all a look
so we're going to jump back over
into our google admin console here and
in the same security menu on the left
hand side we can actually click on
dashboards
wait for those to load out for a second
so
something to make note of here is that
with chrome data protection you're
actually going to get a whole slew of
different
information
we can see chrome high-risk users we can
see individual dlp incidents if we want
to scroll down a little bit we could
actually see how many users are
forgetting their their passwords if i
can figure out how to use a trackpad
here
so we can see user login attempts we can
see for example messages that are
encrypted but we're interested in is
whether or not
those uh those credit card numbers are
making it through so let's go ahead and
drill a little bit into one of these
reports
so we can see every single file uploaded
file downloaded web content upload for
example and we can actually see every
single time that this took place for our
social security detection as well as
credit card detection and if we were
actually drilling on credit card
detection here and i think that's really
cool so i'm going to show everybody real
quick here since we do have like another
minute and that is uh
all the sensitive data transfers that
are taking place blocked detected or
otherwise so even if your organization
isn't using all corporate owned devices
you can still monitor security events
and investigate those alerts
that's awesome marco audience so what do
you think let's let us know in the chat
we definitely know this is something of
interest
in the last 15 minutes you've seen how
entire workforce can access modern and
legacy applications securely how you can
improve threat and data protection and
how you can get better visibility into
risky activity even on unmanaged devices
yeah uh our goal right at the end of the
day with beyond corp enterprise is to
make your experience more productive and
more secure and our team looks forward
to supporting you on your zero trust
journey
thanks so much for joining us today and
participating we have a live q a coming
up next to answer all of your google
cloud security questions as well as any
questions you might have had from the
demo so please stick around
yeah please do and thank you all for
joining we'll see you all soon bye
you